[Music]
so one of the propositions that I set
forth for you last week was that the
most real things are the things that are
most permanent across time and and that
manifests themselves in the largest
number of situations and those are the
things that you have to map successfully
in order to survive survive of
individuals that survive as a species
over a very long period of time and so
the question is one question is what are
the constants of experience if you are a
follower of the evolutionary
psychologists and to some degree the
evolutionary biologist but I would say
more the psychologists like to be in
close metis they have a very afro
centric view of human evolution and the
idea basically is that after we diverged
from the common ancestor between
chimpanzees bonobos and human beings we
spent a tremendous amount of time in the
African environment mostly on the veldt
although we're not absolutely certain
about that we're also very good in water
human beings and we have some of the
features of aquatic mammals so while
hairlessness being one of them women
have a subcutaneously
they are fat or feeder quite nicely
adapted for swimming and so Buckminster
Fuller who I wouldn't call a mainstream
evolutionary psychologist hypothesized
back in the 70s that we spent some
period of time in our evolutionary
history living on beaches near the ocean
that idea really echoes for me because
we like beaches a lot and it's a great
place if you want to get easy food and
we're pretty damn good at swimming for
for terrestrial mammals and we are
hairless and we do cry salt tears and
there's a lot of evidence that we and
our feet if you think about our feet
they're quite flipper like I know we are
stand up and all that and walk so that's
part of the adaptation but we're pretty
good at swimming
so anyways the classical evolutionary
psychology view is that we spent most of
our time on the African veldt it in the
critical period of our evolutionary
development let's say after we diverged
from this common ancestor and that were
adapted for that environment and one of
the consequences of that is the idea
that we're that things have changed so
much around us that we're really not
adapted to the environment that we're in
anymore and I really believe that
because I think that the idea that the
primary forces that shaped our evolution
shaped them during that period of time
call it a roughly a seven million period
year period of time something like that
and that that was somehow a special time
for human evolution that set our nature
I don't believe that I mean it's true to
some degree but it's more useful to view
the evolution of human cognitive
processes over the entire span of
evolutionary history and not necessarily
give preference to any particular epoch
and I certainly believe that the idea
that we're no longer adapted to the
environment because of our rapid
technological transformations is simply
not true and the reason I think that
it's not true is because the fundamental
constants of the environment let's say
or it's more of the fundamental
constants constituent elements of being
I think that's the right way to think
about it they're the same they haven't
changed a bit and there is no way of
changing them as far as I can tell
without us being radically and
incomprehensibly different than we are
and you know with with the rapid rise of
artificial intelligence and robotics and
all of that it's certainly possible then
in five hundred years will be completely
will be so like unlike the way we are
now that we won't even be the same
creatures I don't think that's a
particularly great outcome but it's
certainly possible so what are the
fundamental constituent elements well
they're expressed in mythology but
they're not merely symbolic I think it's
the wrong way to think about it they're
symbolic but they reflect a very deep
reality and they actually reflect a
reality that's not easily apprehensible
directly by the senses
now your senses are tuned for a
particular duration that's roughly
excuse me that's roughly the duration
that you live let's say but more
importantly it's the duration whatever
that duration is across which meaningful
actions take place and we kind of have
some idea of what that duration is you
know if you look at a computer screen if
it has a refresh rate of less than 60
Hertz you can see it's liquor abut above
60 Hertz you can't its uniform and with
movies anywhere between 20 and 50 frames
a second is enough to give you the
illusion of continual motion so you know
we live in a universe that's above the
tenth of a second domain or maybe the
hundredth of a second somewhere in there
anyways and I mean it's not like time
isn't almost infinitely subdivide at
higher levels of resolution than that
but we don't operate generally speaking
at higher temporary
a something approximating 1/2 a second
to a second you know I mean it's an
estimate obviously but a second is a
meaningful unit of time for a person and
a hundredth of a second really isn't and
certainly a billionth of a second isn't
and then you know we can think across
hours and days and weeks and months but
we really can't once you start getting
out in two years it gets kind of sketchy
and it's hard to think more than five
years down the road and the reason for
that is that the particulars upon which
you're basing your predictions are
likely to change sufficiently over a
five year period so that extending out
your vision past that just exposes you
to accelerating error right and that and
of course that's the problem with
predicting the future period so we live
in a time range that's about say a tenth
of a second to three three years
something like that now I know it can
expand beyond up but that's that's kind
of where we're set and our senses seem
to be tuned to those durations and and
to be operative so that we make proper
decisions within those durations and and
also from from a particular spatial
position and so forth you know your eyes
see what's roughly
maybe we could say a walkable distance
in front of you something like that so
then you get detect things and in the
locale that enables you to immediately
interact with things but it isn't
necessarily the case that senses that
are tuned to do that are also tuned to
inform you directly about what the most
permanent things about being itself are
I think that those things have to be
inferred and there's some there's some
supporting evidence for that kind of
thing from from psycholinguistics
there's a level of categorization that
we seem to manifest more or less
automatically or implicitly so for
example when children perceive animals
they they perceive at the level of cat
or dog they don't they don't perceive at
the level of subspecies like Siamese cat
or or or or let's say Samoyed you know
there's this there's a natural I can't
remember what they call that base
category something like that it's
usually specified by very short words
that are easily learn about and so the
linguistic system seems to map right on
to the to the object recognition
characteristics of the sensory systems
that are built right into it and and if
they weren't built into it we couldn't
communicate easily because our natural
categories I think that's it but it's
probably wrong our natural categories
they have to be the same for every one
or it would be very difficult for us to
communicate okay so having said all that
then the question is well what are the
most what are the most real categories
and I think there's there's a real
division in ways to think about this
because there's a scientific way of
thinking about it and and in in that
case the most real categories are well
mathematical equations certainly seem to
be and in the top category there that
equations that describe the physical
universe but then then the hypothesis of
the existence of such things as protons
and and electrons and you know that the
material elements that make up
everything that's every element of being
the possible exception of empty space
but in the in the mythological world the
categories I think are more derived from
Darwinian by the effect of Darwinian
processes on cognitive and perceptual
function so which is to say that we have
learned to perceive and then to infer
those things that are most necessary for
us in order to continue our existence
propagate live well all of those things
and that would be true at the level of
individual survival and maybe it's also
true at the level of growth survival
although you know the there's a
tremendous debate among evolutionary
biologists about whether or not
selection can take place at the level of
the group anyways there are these basic
level categories that manifest
themselves to you and then there's
categories of the imagination that you
have to infer up from the sensory domain
and we do that partly in science by
comparing our sensory representations
across people but we also do it by
thinking abstractly conceptualizing
abstractly and you know one of the
things that's interesting about
abstractions is it's not clear whether
they're more or less real than the
things they're abstracted from you know
that this is a perennial debate among
let's call them ontology who are
interested in that fundamental
fundamental nature of reality itself in
some sense independent of conceptual
structures are numbers more or less real
than the things they represent it's a
really hard question to answer because
knowing like using numbers as a
representational system gives you
unbelievable power and there are
mathematicians that believe that there
isn't anything more real than
mathematical representations now it
depends to some degree of course on how
you classify reality that's the problem
with the question like is a equivalent
to be the answer that always is well it
depends on how you define a and it
depends on how you define B so generally
it's not a very useful question but you
can still get the point that there's
something very real about abstraction
incredibly real because otherwise why
would you bother with them they wouldn't
give you any handle on the world so
what's the what's the most useful or
what's the most what's the broadest
possible level of abstraction and is
there any use of any utility in thinking
in that manner and I tried to
make the case last time that that in the
mythological world there are three
categories or four depending on what you
do with the strange fourth category
there's a fourth category sort of the
category of on categories able entities
and so it's sort of the category of
everything that not only do you not know
but you don't know you don't know it's
it's or you can think about it as the
category of potential I actually think
that's the best way to think about it is
that it's the dragon of chaos is the
category of potential and I do believe
that where our materialist view is
essentially wrong I think that the
proper way of looking at the at being is
that being is potential and from that
potential whatever consciousness is
extracts out the reality that we inhabit
anyways that's certainly the
mythological viewpoint and and but it's
not just a mythological viewpoint it's a
it's a sequence of ideas for example
that deeply underlies the thinking of
young Piaget and Piaget by the way it
was very interested in reconciling the
gap between religion and science that's
really what he devoted his life to doing
and so and there are other streams of
philosophy and I would say Heidegger the
phenomenologist are are thinking along
lines that are similar to this as well
because Heidegger was concerned not with
the nature of material reality but with
being as such and and and so you can
extract out the viewpoint that I just
described from from mythology but it
isn't the only source of such what would
you call it
hi hypotheses is probably the right idea
so the idea you can think about this as
a bootstrapping process in some senses
in order for anything to get going it
has to bootstrap itself up and become
more and more complex as it does that so
it's it's like this is the answer to the
chicken and egg problem right which was
first the chicken or the egg well
neither something from which both the
chicken and egg were derived right
because the the ultimate the ultimate
answer to that is the answer to how
there are things at all who knows but at
some point there were neither chickens
nor eggs but there were the things that
were the precursors to those things and
so they spiraled upwards in some sense
and those in the initial proto anta
tease
single celled animals for I mean you can
go back farther than that but we could
say well single-cell animal is
differentiated over time right and
there's this looping process that that
differentiates out into both the chicken
and the egg so but what the question is
what do you need in order for that
process to begin and that's really the
question of what the fundamental
constituent elements of reality are and
the mythological hypothesis is that
there's or three or four one is the fact
that there has to be something that that
that that manifests itself as an
observer it's something like that some
kind of observer now where that process
of observation starts in the
phylogenetic chain is very very
difficult to tell you know we might say
well there's certainly nothing of a
conscious observer until there's a
differentiated nervous system but then
prior to the emergence of differentiated
nervous systems there were animals that
were complex enough to react with the
environment in a manner that well
single-celled animals they're quite
complex I mean some of them are
unbelievably complicated you know they
can move themselves through space they
can orient they can follow chemical
trails they're not they're not stupid by
any stretch of the imagination now to
what degree they have being you know as
something they could represent well we
don't have to speculate on that but the
proto elements of conscious being are
there so you need you need a being you
need that the structure of that being
through which the the entirety of being
itself is interpreted and you need the
surround it's something like that and so
I conceptualize that as something that
knows that's the knower what it knows
that's the interpretive structure and
that which needs to be known or you
could could conceptualize that as the
individual in explored territory nested
inside unexplored territory that's
another way of thinking about it or you
can think about it as the individual
inside culture and the individual
culture has nested inside nature that's
another way of looking at it or you can
think of it but as the knower and in
order surrounded by chaos
that's another way of thinking about it
but all these things you know they're
all attempts to articulate the same
underlying structure you see that in
narratives continually and I think
Pinocchio is a very good example of that
because in Pinocchio you have the
culture that's Geppetto and Geppetto is
obviously creative but also insufficient
and dead which is why he ends up in the
belly of the whale you have the Blue
Fairy whose mother nature for all
intents and purposes the negative
feminine doesn't manifest itself much in
the Pinocchio story except implicitly in
the form of the whale the thing at the
bottom that which is more like the
dragon of chaos than something feminine
that swallows up the swallows up culture
but you have nature or culture Geppetto
nature the blue fairy and then the
puppet Pinocchio and you know from a
strictly scientific perspective we think
of human beings as nothing but the
children of nature and culture and that
pushes you towards a kind of
deterministic view what causes your
behavior well it's either nature or
culture because there isn't anything
else but that isn't how the mythological
story lays itself out because it says
there is something else and that's
whatever your consciousness is and that
consciousness seems to be able to work
with nature and culture in a non
deterministic manner in order to bring
well in order for what in order to bring
itself forward I mean and that's really
and what's interesting about that I
think is that it isn't obviously just
the plot of Pinocchio it's virtually the
plot of any story is the story of the
development of the individual now the
story is order chaos higher order
roughly speaking so you can get variants
of that you can get order collapses into
disorder and nothing is resolved that's
a tragedy right and and you can get so
so you don't have to have the entire
story represented in this story but you
get fragments of it it's a classic
u-shaped story and what it is is the
story of the development of the
individual across time as a consequence
of his or her adventures in time and
space and every story is exactly that
and those are representations of the
manner in which you come to be in the
world for better or for worse it's
differentiated so the individual has a
negative and a pause development and
culture has a negative and a positive
element the nature does as well and that
makes the potential for plots much
broader but and I think it's also very
useful to know that entire story because
I think it's one of the things that
protects you against ideology it's like
okay where if someone tells you a
political story or a story of any sort
you can always ask well where are the
missing characters human beings are
terrible they directed a culture that's
destroying the planet and nature is been
if you know benevolent and and pristine
it's like yeah fair enough accurate but
you missing half the characters because
humans are not just terrible rapacious
creatures and culture is not just a
destructive force and nature is by no
means on our side so where's the missing
characters you need all the characters
in the representation to get it right
and I really believe this to be true so
for example if you want to protect
yourself against trauma as you move
forward in life you have to be very
aware of the three three negative
characters you have to know that the
human individual has an adversarial
element that's malevolent right to the
core and if you don't know that and you
run across someone who's malevolent you
will end up damaged so because first you
won't be able to defend yourself you'll
just be like a ripe fruit tree for the
plucking and second the mere existence
of someone like that will pose such a
threat to the way that you've organized
the world that it might collapse on you
that happens to people all the time so
it really matters whether you know these
categories and it matters that you know
that culture can become tyrannical it
really but that it's also you're the
father that's given you everything and
it matters that you know everything good
comes from nature and that we need to
live in harmony with nature to some
degree but that it's also hell bent on
our destruction every second and it's
very paradoxical it's a hard thing to
reconcile with with with a with a
thought structure like modern science
that's based on a strict logic that
always says something can't be itself
and it's opposite at the same time but
you know human beings can certainly be
something and it's opposite at the same
time and anything truly complex can have
the
and does have that nature if someone
offers you a new job you think well
that's positive it's like no it's not
it's positive and negative and complex
it might be the solution to your problem
but at the same set time it's going to
generate a whole host of other problems
so lots of times we're encountering
entities in some sense that have an
internally paradoxical structure and we
have to deal with that entire set of
paradoxes or or we don't survive it's
really a matter of survival okay so so
on and then you know there's this
overarching symbol which is the dragon
of chaos which is potential itself and
it's the potential from which all of
these categories emerge and so the the
most abstract category of our
imagination is that which is beyond our
understanding the category of that which
is beyond our understanding and that
seems to me to be represented because we
can only use the representational
structures that we evolved is that it's
represented in our paradoxical
representation of the predator and the
treasure that lies beyond the perimeter
is the perimeters of our safe societies
so what's out there beyond well we don't
know but we need to know because we need
always to deal with what we don't know
so weirdly enough we have to come up
with a category of what we don't know in
order to start formalizing a theory
about how we might progress towards it
and interact with it it's a very
paradoxical idea and there's a
paradoxical answer right it's the
terrible predator that lurks in the
unknown that also harbors something of
great value perfect perfect that's
exactly right that's exactly right
and and I think that that is a
reflection of the fact that human beings
are predator animal and prey animals at
the same time so what's out there in the
terrible darkness something that can
destroy you but also something that you
absolutely need so how do you how do you
prepare yourself for that and that's the
ultimate question of life it's not how
do you deal with death although death is
a sub component of the terrible unknown
I would say it's how do you deal with
that which is beyond your understanding
which is constantly manifesting itself
in the world and that and that manifests
itself every time you
categorize something and the thing
escapes from the category and that
happens most interpersonal relationships
because people are so damn complicated
you get them figured out boxed in you
can make a contract that neither of you
will jump outside the box but you jump
outside the box continually and that's
why a relationship requires constant
negotiation and reconceptualize ation
because you do not exhaust the person
with your perceptual categories and of
course you don't exhaust the world with
your perceptual categories ever this is
partly why the existentialist or they
have this concept called alienation and
the idea was that human beings become
alienated from their creative products
so and that is and here's why it happens
so imagine Henry Ford makes the assembly
line right so Ford has no idea what's
going to happen when he makes the
assembly line like because he's just
trying to figure out a fast way to make
cars or he thinks that what he's making
his cars so he thinks he's making an
assembly line for cars and he thinks
he's making cars and you think well
what's wrong with that well first of all
the assembly line absolutely transformed
the entire planet right because it
brought in that the era of mass cheap
manufacturing it's like it's just it was
way more than he thought it was and then
did he make a car well a car is
something that hypothetically takes you
relatively effectively from point A to
point B it was really a replacement for
the horse and buggy I mean if the first
cars looked like that they were
horseless carriages
well did he make a car well god it's God
it's hard to tell what Henry Ford made
he made a very effective way for
transforming the atmosphere right and
the fact that it also happened to take
you from point A to point B might be
just completely irrelevant compared to
the fact that it was the internal
combustion engine and its rapid
distribution completely changed the
constituent that you know the
fundamental chemical structure of the
atmosphere itself it completely
transformed cities it blew out the rural
community everyone moved to the cities
right it made all the cities built
around the automobile but then it had
this tremendous political and economic
significance too so I mean part of the
reason that because you think well is a
car is a way to get from point A to
point B but no no it's not a machine
it's also the embodiment of an idea it's
a very strange idea a collectivist
society would have never invented the
car because the car is predicated on the
idea that you could own a conveyance
that would get only you and only you
from somewhere to somewhere else
without ever asking anybody for any
permission and so the funny thing is is
when you build something like that those
presuppositions are built into it and
then when you export that say to Soviet
Russia you don't get to they can't just
take the car and leave the political
implications behind the car the foot
mere fact that you stepped into one and
drive it is an indication that you're
accepting the political ideological
presuppositions that are part of the
fact that that thing even exists and so
well that's alienation it's like even
something you make you think well you
have control over what you make because
you've made it you understand it's like
no you don't you understand a tiny
fraction of it you launch it out in the
world man and the snakes inside of it
the Hydra Xinhai inside of it
multiply their heads massively
constantly and you can you can't really
keep track of it and so so even even in
your relationship with create identities
you still see the re-emergence of this
underlying fundamental sub structure
right even inside it's the it's the
Garden of Eden there's always a snake
inside the thing this wall did always
always all even God himself could not
get rid of the snakes in the garden and
partly what that means is that you know
the garden is a conceptual system it's
the conceptual system within which
people exist that Eden is a is a walled
garden paradise means walled garden and
it's walls because a walled garden is
where people live because the wall is
culture and the garden is nature and we
always live in a structure that's an
amalgam of nature and culture so we set
it up so it's paradisal as long as we're
unconscious but we can't manage it
because there's always something chaotic
that's coming in that we will interact
with that's human beings you put a snake
in the garden it's the first bloody
thing we're going to talk to and for
better or worse it makes us conscious
and awake it makes us aware of our
mortality it does all sorts of terrible
things to us but it doesn't matter
because that's that's the path that
human
beings have what chosen because that's
the implication in that story and and
it's very difficult it's a very
difficult thing to answer because we
certainly choose each other for
self-awareness and consciousness and
intelligence and I don't you know if
you're if you're choosing a mate there's
an arms race in human beings we're
choosing intelligent mate especially
that's especially the case for women in
relationship to men so so that the idea
is that that's a choice well that's
partly why it's Eva that makes Adam
self-conscious in the Garden of Eden
right she offers him the Apple she's the
one that makes him self-conscious I
think that's actually accurate because
the evidence from the evolutionary
biologist is that human sexual females
sexual selection was one of the driving
factors that differentiated us for
chimpanzees it's a major factor
chimpanzee females are not selective
mater's they go into estrus they'll mate
with anything what happens is the
dominant males chase the subordinate
males away and so they end up leaving
more offspring but it's not a
consequence of selection on the part of
the females and human beings it's
completely different concealed ovulation
and intense selection pressure from
women on men you have twice as many
female ancestors as you have male
ancestors people can never have a hard
time working that oh there is medically
but it's not that problematic you just
think on average every woman had one
child half of men had none and the other
half had two and that's approximately
correct if you average across the entire
history of human sexuality so human
males in particular are subject to
vicious selection pressure on the part
of females and I also think that's
partly why nature is represented
symbolically as female among human
beings because after all nature is what
selects there's no better definition of
nature than that which selects so now so
so here's here's what I want to talk to
you about the brain a little bit because
if you make the radical case let's say
that these are actually the categories
of reality and we're going to say well
reality is what select for the for the
sake of for this for the sake of
argument then the then are our
neurological struck
our physical structure should be adapted
to that reality it's it's a necessary
conclusion from that so then the
question is well are they and as far as
I can tell the answer to that is yes and
so we'll go through the what would neuro
psychological evidence quite rapidly the
first bit of evidence is that you have
two hemispheres why one deals with
unknown and the other deals with the
known that's Alcona and goldberg that's
that hypothesize completely
independently of any of this underlying
mythological substructure which is
really important thing to note because
if you're trying to determine whether or
not something is true valid if it's the
construct upon which you base your
thinking are valid and true there's
rules for doing that and one of the
rules is you have to be able to detect
the existence of the categories using
multiple methods of of what using
multiple methods
it's the multi method multi trait matrix
technically speaking it was established
as a technique by two psychologists
named cronbach cro NB a CH and me'll ma
eh L Paul Mele back in the 1950s which
psychologists were trying to figure out
how do you determine if something
actually has an existence like anger or
anxiety that's something that you could
study scientifically and the answer is
well you have to be able to measure it
multiple ways and all those measurements
have to read the same way and then the
question is well what do you mean by
multiple ways because it's sight and
vision in sight and hearing different or
somewhat and somewhat to say but you
know you make them as different as you
can manage let's say and our sensory
systems are quite different smell
molecular signature sound is auditory
print or you know auditory pressure you
need a gas around you or some liquid in
order for that to occur sight uses light
you know we're using different inputs
that converge and allow us to say well
if we get convergence information across
these multiple measurements then we'll
assume that the thing we're perceiving
is real we even extend that in science
because we say if you take your multiple
measurement system and you take your
multiple multiple measurement system and
then you compare them will only allow
what's corn
to cross both those comparisons to be
real and so that's the multi method
multi trait matrix process essentially
and my sense is that you know I think
that the pattern that I'm describing to
you is manifested itself evolutionarily
it manifests itself at the neural in the
neurological space and it manifests
itself in the conceptual space and the
probabilities of all three of those
things happening at the same time
without there being something valid
there is lessons with each level of
interpretation you managed to stack on
top of one another so that's that's the
method well so let's think about the
brain a little bit and I'll tell you a
little bit about how the brain works and
and you know a lot of the stuff I'm
telling you right now is quite old
actually most of it was worked out in
the nineteen in the 1980s but it's been
remarkably stable as far as I can tell
in some sense we're filling in the
details and not in every sense but in
some sense we're filling in the details
okay so you take this is from Alexander
Luria who was the the greatest perhaps
the greatest neuropsychologist who ever
lived he was a Russian what worked
mostly up to the Second World War mostly
on people who had brain damage and he
was interested in trying to outline the
the overarching picture of brain
function and so he did that partly by
looking at its function but also partly
by looking at its structure trying to
get both of those things working
simultaneously and so we'll go through a
brief picture of how the brain works and
so one of the ways of so you can you can
look at the brain from front to back and
you can divide it roughly into two
sections in one section has to do with
sensory processing and that's roughly
the back half and one section has to do
with motor output now those things
aren't as clearly differentiated as you
might think because you there's very
little sensation without motor output
maybe the the part that closest to an
exception is smell I would say but you
at least have to breathe in you know and
when an animal is actively searching on
a scent trail its breathing in so it's
using its motor output constantly to
modify the sensory stream it's really
difficult to dissociate the two it when
you're looking at some
you know it kind of feels to you like
you're a passive recipient of sense data
but you're no such thing your eyes are
moving back and forth in multiple ways
all the time including the ways that you
can control voluntarily so there's
multiple involuntary systems that are
moving your eyes in multiple ways and
really what you're doing is feeling the
the array of electro-magnetic of the
electromagnetic spectrum with your eyes
you're feeling it you're actively
exploring if you're not a passive
recipient at all so even in sensation
you can't purely pull sensation out for
motor processing and say I'm getting
untrammeled unbiased sense data because
you can't look at something without
focusing and you can't focus without
wanting to look at something you know
you can't just lie there with it well
you could with your eyes have cross but
you know that's sort of like imagine you
dropped a video recorder from an
airplane and it just spun around in an
unfocused manner well that's the world
sampled randomly you know what are you
going to do with that nothing and you
know you're you're concentrating on the
on on the auditory stream constantly and
segregating out some things and
suppressing others like if you listen in
the classroom you can hear probably four
or five different types of mechanical
noise going on at the same time most of
the time in the classroom that's silent
you don't hear it like you don't hear
your fridge except when it turns on or
off right you zero that out and so
you're very selective in your perception
so you can't really technically separate
out motor output from sensory input and
that's really useful to know because it
destroys the idea that you're just a pet
you know that there's a world of
sensation out there that's imprinting
itself on you and that's how you get
your information which is really the
that's the fundamental presupposition of
the empiricists of the raw empiricists
there's a world of sense data out there
you sample it randomly and that's what
informs like yes except that you're
always an active harvester of the
information so you can't get rid of the
interpretive structure a priori that was
a manual cat by the
who first established out in his
critique of pure reason you can't get
away from the fact that you're actively
harvesting the data so you can say well
where is human structure come from
defense data that's sort of the blank
slate idea it's like no wrong because a
blank slate cannot process information
you're actively engaged right at the
beginning so that's another example of
the knower and the unknown you know
working in the cyclical manner because
you interact with something you divide
it up into you you and the world roughly
speaking and I mean you really make it
that way because you build yourself out
of the information and then of course
that makes you a more differentiated
processor with a broader range of skills
then you interact with the unknown again
you gather more information it
differentiates the world it makes you a
more differentiated harvester and then
so it's just continually cycling and
that consciousness the logos the knower
is that thing that's doing that
harvesting and you can never say it's
not there now what happens is that it's
in its nascent form to begin with low
resolution nascent form low resolution
or low resolution category system low
resolution world but that's enough to
kick started and to started
differentiating and that happens as you
develop as an individual because you
start out as a single-celled organism
for all intents and purposes a very low
resolution thing in a very low
resolution world and that differentiates
itself across time but exactly the same
thing happened over evolutionary time so
so there isn't a time when those three
elements aren't there for all intents
and purposes they're always there
they're permanent okay so anyways back
to the brain since sensory unit that's
the that's the back half roughly
speaking huge chunk of that is devoted
to visual processing in human beings
right most animals organized around
smells not us some what still can smell
is a very powerful evoker of memories
and it has a direct relationship with
emotional systems because you need to
know if something is edible or inedible
terrible or or good very very rapidly
but human beings are organized around
vision so we have a map
of massive amounts of our cortex devoted
to differentiated visual processing now
the motor unit so what you have is each
of these little zones here so for
example look at the back here that's the
primary visual area and the secondary
visual area and then this is the primary
auditory area in the middle of the brain
here on the outside and the secondary
auditory area and then the the this is
for body representation the primary area
in the secondary area and you can think
about those those areas of primary
primary secondary and then tertiary
primary does the base level processing
tertiary expands that up into more
abstract represent a secondary expands
it up into more abstract representations
and tertiary are the areas where the
senses come together and that's really
what what you seem to be most conscious
of right
it's action in the tertiary areas
because you don't really see the world
as a separate you can think about the
auditory streams separate from the
visual stream and all of that and you
can think about touch separately but you
tend to consciously experience things as
a unity as a comprehensive unity of all
the senses simultaneously so
consciousness seems to occur only at
that most of the time at the highest
level of integration and you'll area
would have associated consciousness more
with the tertiary areas where this where
the senses are talking to one another
now it's more complicated than that
because there's obviously subcortical
structures all the way down to the spine
that are involved heavily in what
consciousness is it's not merely a
consequence of cortical activity you
know we tend to think that because human
beings have massively expanded cortical
structures and we think of ourselves as
the most conscious creatures and that's
reasonable but you can take an awful lot
of cortex off someone and they're still
conscious in fact you can leave them
with almost no brain at all and they're
still conscious so we really have a
rough time trying to figure out what
consciousness is and how it's related to
brain structure so anyway so that's the
sensory and then the motor unit you have
the primary unit the secondary unit and
the Primo
or the prefrontal cortex and prefrontal
cortex is particularly a huge and human
being so imagine that it's this primary
and secondary areas that allow you to -
first of all to act voluntarily and then
- and then to play around in some sense
with your actions
you know like imagine that imagine that
you're a child building with Legos and
you can sync with the Legos without
without really having to think
abstractly right because you can play
around and build different sorts of
structures until you can think at the
level at a level of motor output without
having to depend on abstraction but if
you develop the prefrontal cortex here
which emerged out of the motor and
premotor areas over the course of
evolution so it's a differentiation of
those structures so this is dealing with
the real world this is dealing mostly
with the real world but starting to
abstract and experiment a little bit and
then this what this part deals with
abstractions pure and simple so you know
I can I can I can lift this and then I
can play with lifting it and then I can
put it aside and think about it
abstractly I can think about all the
different things that I might do with it
I say well I could throw it I could take
it apart I could throw I could toss it
in the air I could juggle it I could use
it as a doorstop right I could kick it
across the room and so basically what
I'm doing there is I'm using my
prefrontal cortex to generate an
abstract representation of the world and
then to plot out motor strategies before
implementing them and that's basically
what abstract thought is very very
fundamentally it's it's it's the
hypothesis of abstract action and then
the analysis of the outcome and then the
implementation into action and I think
that there's something about that that
actually defines the difference between
intelligence and conscientiousness
because weirdly enough you know the
correlation between intelligence and
conscientiousness is zero no
relationship whatsoever it's quite
strange because conscientious people
plan and and so forth but I think what
it is is that intelligence is an
indicator of the effectiveness of
abstraction and conscientiousness is an
indicator of the probability of
implementation and those are very
very different problems and you don't
just go from abstraction to
implementation because if you did you
wouldn't be able to think right the
thinking has to be torn away from the
implementation or what you're doing
isn't thinking it's just acting so and
so I think that accounts for the
psychometric independence of those two
phenomena it's annoying because you can
think of something that you should do
and you won't do it because there's no
deterministic causal pathway from the
conception to the action so that's kind
of annoying it seems to take something
like willpower in order to transform the
abstraction into an implementation and
we don't understand that very well it's
easy to understand the resistance to
doing it because Moke the default
position of your body should be
something like no it never do anything
except eat you know because doing
something requires the expenditure of
energy and resources and so unless you
have a really good rationale for it you
should probably not do it and so the
body is sort of intransigent by Nature
it's an oversimplification you have to
come up with a good reason to impel it
into motion and you should because you
have to pay for action you have to pay
for it with energy and resources so
there should be resistance against it
but it's still annoying so ok so that's
one way of thinking about the world the
world something to sense and the world
something to act upon and so the brain
has fundamental divisions of sensing and
acting upon but there it's a constantly
interacting loop you can't separate them
really any more than we are separating
them conceptually now on the motor strip
here
the body is represented and this was
discovered at the Montreal Neurological
Institute when when when brain surgery
was been doing was being done on on on
people generally who had epilepsy or
some other terrible brain illness you
have brain surgery when you're awake
which is a rather horrifying thing to
know about but the reason for that
generally speaking is so that something
isn't taken out that you need now one of
the things that happened while people
were having brain surgery done and this
would have been I believe I don't
remember the exact time between the 30s
and the 50s I believe and I think it was
hab if I remember properly who was one
of Canada's great neuropsychologist we
do brain stimulation while people were
having brain surgery and they could map
out the way the body was represented on
the cortical surface and so you imagine
there's two representations there's
there's a sensory representation of your
body on the cortical surface and there's
a motor representation of your body on
the cortical surface those are both
called the representations are called
homunculus they're like the body has
been laid out on this strange strip or
this strip of tissue you can look up the
homunculi and see what they're like but
I'll show you uh they're sort of
stretched out weirdly along here that
would be the motor one and then along
here that would be the sensory one and
you can kind of you can kind of detect
with your own consciousness how your
body is represented in your brain so for
example can I get you to stand up if you
would let's turn around okay so how many
fingers on your back okay all right why
low resolution he's like a rope on the
honor his back is like a low resolution
array of pixels right and so it's
virtually impossible you just don't have
enough sensory tissue on your back to
make that you could tell I was pushing
but it could have been a bath it could
have been five fingers it doesn't matter
maybe your pixel is this big
or something like that right and so but
if I put a finger on your lip like that
man you've got it right now or on your
tongue because your tongue there's more
representative representation of your
tongue than your entire trunk and well
why well you don't to bite your tongue
that's a big problem you have to be able
to talk you you want to really
differentiate what you're eating if
you're eating fish you don't want to eat
the bone so and you know when your
tongue is unbelievably crazily sensitive
and you know that to that if you have a
tooth pulled
your tongue will investigate that area
for like six months what you're sitting
there your attention wanes and your
tongue is in there like mapping like mad
mapping that little hole to update your
body representation right and it's just
this crazy thing that is unbelievably
well represented set from the sensory
perspective and also from the motor
perspective because you could manipulate
your tongue like crazy
it's it's like a quarter of your motor
output system is devoted to tongue
manipulation right and so here's a
here's a picture of the homunculus this
is a motor homunculus so that's how
that's what your brain thinks of your
body that that's a good way of thinking
about it and so that's what a human
being is like in terms of his or her
output and so what you see if you look
at a sensory homunculus it's quite
similar except the feet are bigger the
genitalia are bigger logically they
don't have much motor utility but they
have a lot of sensory utility but the
rest of its quite similar so there's you
know the motor and the sensory
homunculus are quite similar but I'm
going to talk about the motor homunculus
because it's sort of the action
representation well so what are human
beings like well we're all hands that's
the first thing you know and if you do
that there's no it's unbelievably high
resolution your fingertips and and and
the and the that sensory but we can
manipulate our hands like crazy like
they're unbelievably articulated right
and that's the thing that makes us able
to change the world it makes us what
dolphins aren't and so a huge part of
our brain is devoted towards being able
to move our hands that enables us to
take things apart put them together
and then once we learn to take things
apart and put them together we can talk
about how we do that and that's a lot of
what we're doing and that's the hands
and the mouth and the tongue roughly
speaking here's how I took something to
get apart chaos here's what I made out
of it order here's how I did it and then
you receive that and you're happy about
it and then you can do the same thing
that's invitation facilitated by
language like here's what I did with my
body
I'm propagating the cross space you're
taking it mapping it onto your body now
you can do the same thing yeah and
that's you know it might be simple like
this is how you pick up a rock but it
might be complicated like here's how you
go after the dragon of chaos right and
so that's it sort of maps on to that
hierarchy this thing that we talked
about in some detail this when you're
telling a story to people when you're
informing them about something you can
talk to them at a very high level of
resolution what you do with your child
here's how you slice up some broccoli
right but then you move up the
obstruction so here's how you act like a
civilized person at the dinner table
right and that's part of being a good
person so you can tell stories about I
just went and saw Logan I really like by
the way it's super violent but I really
did like it it's got a very elegant
mythological structure which is not
surprising but there's a scene in this
Logan movie he it's not a spoiler he has
this child with him who has not been I
was being raised roughly in a laboratory
and she has absolutely no table manners
and so they're sitting at the dinner
with some people that they run into and
she's you know eating like a total
barbarian and of course everybody's
eyebrows are raised like where did this
person come from so the fact that that
high order behavior isn't there is
something that's of extraordinary
interest to everyone and so you know you
teach your children microStrategy's and
you teach the macro strategies some of
the macro strategies you're teaching
them you don't even understand because
you know you know the strategies they're
built into you because of an
evolutionary process roughly speaking
and you say things like it doesn't
matter whether you win or lose it
matters
you play the game and you don't
understand what that means although you
know it's right and you try to act that
out for your children and they
incorporate it in their action even
though they can't represent it they
cannot come up with a fully articulated
representation of what that means and so
they're like children piagetian children
children can only play by themselves to
begin with while they're integrating
themselves internally then they start to
play in parallel with other children so
you'll your - you play your game that
child plays his or her game a little
interaction but you can't unite the
games then you're between 2 & 4 you
start to be able to unite the games and
you can either do that by acting them
out you can do this even with the
younger child they can catch peekaboo
very rapidly but once you're between 2 &
4 and you start getting linguistic you
can start saying well let's play this
game and that means we're going to unite
our attention towards a particular goal
we're going to unite our motor activity
and maybe cooperate and compete towards
that goal the beginning of the social
structure the beginning of the social
structure and you get really good at
that between 2 & 4 but you don't
necessarily know what you're doing you
can't say it
so pjs experiments indicated that if you
take children maybe they've got to the
point where they can play quite a social
game maybe they're 5 or 6 they're
playing marbles you take them out of the
game and you say okay tell me the rules
of the game of marbles
they give incoherent representations why
because their behavior is more
sophisticated than their representation
you see as soon as you understand that
that is a wild thing to understand
because it answers the question for
example how can you have dreams that
tell you things you don't know you think
well how the hell can that possibly be
you're coming up with the damn dream how
can the dream tell you things you don't
know or analogously how can people tell
stories that contain information that
they don't understand an answer is the
information is coded in our behavior
okay so we'll go back to a chimpanzee
troop all the chimpanzees in the troop
know the dominant hierarchy structure
but if you take a chimpanzee out from
the troop and say what's the dominant
structure the chimpanzee is going to
do whatever a chimpanzee does it's not
going to have a little conversation with
you about the nature of the dominant
hierarchy so it can act out its
knowledge and it might even be able to
represent it an image but it can't
articulate it well why would we be any
different we aren't obviously because
we're more complex than we understand so
the fact that we're more complex than we
understand means that we contain
information that we cannot articulate
why can't that reveal itself it does all
the time you have a revelation
aha I get it well what is that it's
maybe you're in psychotherapy and we
talk about some things about your past
we say well this happened then this hop
and then this happened look there's a
pattern Wow and it's overwhelming it's
like now there's a concordance between
your knowledge and the things that
you're acting out and that's what comes
as a revelation so one of the things
that happens in Exodus Moses is leading
his people through the desert classic
u-shaped story they're in eternity to
begin with right so that's the that's
the insufficient present that's the old
order then they cross the water
the destructive water that's chaos like
the flood then they're out in the desert
wandering without direction they start
worshipping idols they're wandering
without direction and then Moses goes up
on the mountain which is by the way what
happens in Logan just because if you're
going to go see it you might as well
know that because it's a journey up a
mountain he goes up the mountain and he
gets rules revealed to them well the way
the story is structured is just ordinary
interesting because Moses takes his
people away from this peer net
tyrannical structure but they don't go
from tyranny to paradise to the promised
land in one move that isn't how it works
they have to they go from eternity to
absolute chaos where everyone is
fighting and killing each other and
having a terrible time of it in half
starving and and having to pass through
the Red Sea like it's they go from
tyranny to catastrophe before they go to
higher order and Moses doesn't even make
it to the place of higher order he dies
before he gets there so it's quite the
catastrophe and the Israelites are all
confused when they're out in the desert
because
even though they were in a tyranny and
they were slaves now they're nowhere and
they don't know anything it's not good
and so a lot of them actually start
thinking about how good the damn tyranny
was compared to wandering around in the
desert which is exactly what happened in
the Soviet Union right in Russia now
there's huge nostalgia for the Stalinist
era so these stories they're always true
they're always happening so anyways what
happens to Moses is that the story is
quite interesting so the Israelites
start to fight amongst themselves which
of course they do because there's no
higher order Authority and so then Moses
sits and judges the like literally like
a judge he sits for hours every day and
the squabbling Israelites come up and
say you know he did this to me and oh
you did this to me and and so then Moses
has to figure out who's right and who's
wrong and he's doing this for like hours
and hours for days and days for weeks
and weeks for months it's like the
origin of English common law it's
exactly what happened with common law
because in common law what happens is
that you have all the rights there are
if you to have a dispute you go before
the judiciary you sort out the dispute
that becomes the precedent now that's
part of the body of laws the body of
laws is what you act out that's why it's
a body well that's what Moses does so
he's sitting there making judgments very
very finely tuned discreet moral
judgments you know how difficult that is
when two people have a dispute to try to
figure out how to mediate between that
you don't know who's lying who's telling
the truth you don't know exactly what an
acceptable solution would be like it's
really ridiculously hard work so he
walks through this entire process of
continual judicial intermediation then
he goes up the mountain and what does he
get
tablet a rule well why well he spent his
ten thousand hours investigating the
structure of morality in a practical way
and it goes bang this is what we've been
doing these are the rules it's not like
there's no rules to begin with and those
those are opposed because that wouldn't
work it doesn't work that way you have
to take how people are extract out what
the pattern of what they are is reflect
that back to the
well that's that's the story of Moses
and it's it's it's a myth it's a meta
story it's a story about how rules come
to be we act a certain way we have
certain kinds of expectations we have
certain kinds of disputes out of that a
pattern a pattern way of being emerges
then we map the pattern way of being we
say well look here's the rules there's
ten of them or however many you want to
extract right I mean it's a moving
target in some sense don't kill other
people that's a bad idea
don't steal what other people have order
your parents etc etc I mean either you
could come up with a different basic set
of rules but there'd be some overlap and
those aren't bad to begin with course
there were far more rules than that but
those were the central ones and so then
you might say hey if you took all ten of
those rules and you try to extract out
one rule from them that would be at the
top of the hierarchy what would that be
and in Western culture the idea there is
that do you want others as you would
have them do unto you is the rule that
it's the meta rule that guides all other
rules sort of like the one ring in the
in the Lord of the Rings and so it's
this consistent pattern of abstraction
of ethical guidelines so okay so well
until that maps on - well there's a
there's a micro there's a micro level
that you instruct people at and that
then there's a more abstract level that
you would struck them out and then
there's a more abstract level well maybe
at that point you can't exactly directly
instruct them remember in the Pinocchio
story Geppetto sits pinoke or the
cricket jiminy sits Pinocchio down and
tries to lecture to him about what the
highest level of moral virtue is he
sounds like a complete fraud he sounds
like a propaganda artist he's a soapbox
preacher and Pinocchio doesn't
understand them at all
why has to be acted out now maybe as a
parent you can be a model for emulation
which is so you're a model for imitation
what you say matters but it doesn't say
as much matter as much as what you do
maybe it would if what you said and what
you did were the same that's the ideal
situation like that's what you want to
do if you're a parent if you say one
act differently your kids will torture
you to death and their right to do it -
because you're confused and confusing
them makes them anxious and aggressive
and they will go after you consistency
consistency consistency and if you can't
provide it you'll drive them crazy so
you want to bring your words and your
actions into alignment right and that's
part of the development of wisdom so
okay so back to the brain all right so
this is there it's the motor homunculus
so now what I want to tell you about
that is you just just think about what
this thing is like it's taking the world
apart and it's talking about it so
that's what a human being is like and
that to me that's kind of an image of
the mythological hero it's the thing
that can speak magic words and take the
worlds apart take the world apart now in
one of the stories I'm going to tell you
today which is the story of the ANU
mulisch which is the oldest written
story that we have it's a Mesopotamian
story and it's from the same pool of
stories that the creation account in
Genesis was extracted it isn't obvious
what the temporal sequence was but
imagine there was a pool of stories in
the Middle East that were of indefinite
age tens of thousands of years and and
each of them were developed in a
slightly different way although the
themes underneath were were similar
there are great parallels between the
Mesopotamian creation account and the
first part of the creation account in
Genesis so it was discovered in the late
1900s and Isis just destroyed a huge
treasure trove of that sort of
manuscripts so just so you know
so at Nineveh so we can we can thank the
war in the Middle East for the
destruction of huge a huge treasure
house of irreplaceable human knowledge
and a lot of that's happening that's
happening very very frequently it's an
absolute bloody disgraceful catastrophe
so anyway so you know that that's the
human being lips tongues hands and the
face your face is also extraordinarily
amenable to voluntary manipulation so
you can learn to move
neurons in the tissue underneath your
eyes that's how that's how
high-resolution your face is and that's
part because it's a broadcast screen
which is why people are always looking
at it right and that's why if you watch
a movie it's always concentrating on
people's faces because they're just
broadcasting what they're broadcasting
their stories constantly and we're
looking at their faces what are you
looking at what are your eyes pointing
at what are you up to what's your
emotional expression what are you going
to do next what do you think about me
where are you going and you're brought
like you find someone who has had too
much plastic surgery uncanny because
their face is dead because you cannot
tell what they're up to there they've
got this is aam be like aspect that's
terrifying and people like that
look people like that got killed that's
why we're not like that or they didn't
make like you want to know what that
other person is up to I told you already
that's how the whites of our eyes evolve
right I don't you remember that story
gorillas don't have that distinction
between the iris and the white not like
human beings and our eyes are very sharp
and one thing we really want to know is
what are you looking at and why what are
you up to and if I can tell what you're
looking at I can infer what you're going
to do and you want a broadcast dot well
except when you don't want to broadcast
it but you know most of the time you
want to be pretty transparent to other
people because otherwise they won't
trust you and if they don't trust you
they won't cooperate with you
they won't compete with you and the
probability that they'll come after you
is extraordinarily high because you'll
be evil predator in no time flat so okay
so we'll take a look at the brain from
another perspective now a lot of this I
got from alcone and Goldberg well that's
not exactly right I had laid I laid this
out before that but I found alcohol and
Goldberg's writings afterwards and he
was a student of larious and he was
trying to account for the why we had
different hemispheres roughly speaking
because it's not self-evident that we
should they're actually somewhat two
separate consciousnesses and they
communicate but the communication isn't
complete it's like our brain is
modularized and unified at the same time
and you can think about it like a me
of people why do you want it mod your
modularized well so if one person goes
down all of them don't that's one one
reason so it's some separation of
function why else well each little
module can do its own creative thing
independently of the others and that's
useful and then there can be
communication between them and so
there's there's utility and modularity
and there's utility and integration and
part of what we're trying to work out on
the global political scene right now is
how modular things should be and how
integrated they should be and the
european community rushed into
integration and that's bothering people
dreadfully because they feel that the
advantages of modularization have been
washed away
you saw that maybe they're right because
you saw what happened with greece
collapsed right and greece is very very
corrupt incredibly corrupt and germany
whatever else you might think about
germany is not corrupt and so the EEC
tried to bring Greece and Germany
together that didn't work there was no
unity there the modularity was actually
useful and the fact that Greece was so
destabilized and Italy also very corrupt
and Spain also very corrupt was very
shaky just about brought the whole thing
down it the argument is the modularity
would have been better conserved well
who knows right because modularity is
useful and so is integration but full
integration seems to be a mistake and so
does full modularity how do you get that
right we don't know that's why we're
arguing about it and right now there's a
backlash we're pulling away from the
integration and you you can see why -
because in 2008 was the American economy
collapsed the world economy just about
collapsed that seems like a bad idea you
know you might want some some
separateness so that if one system
malfunctions and goes down the whole
bloody thing doesn't go into flames and
so we don't know we don't know how to
manage that it's a really really
complicated problem so anyways ok so how
does the how does the brain work well
the left roughly speaking in right
handed mail and the reason that I'm
concentrating on right-handed males is
because they're simpler in their
neurological structure when
have a more complicated neurological
structure and left-handed people tend to
structure so we'll just say that we'll
just go with the standard model to begin
with and you can assume that the same
systems are there in every person but
they're not laid out on the hemispheric
structure quite as neatly but they're
still there so it's sort of like these
are tendencies so for example if you're
a so there's a tendency for the right
hemisphere to specialize for what's
relatively unknown and the left
relatively mastered and you could think
about it this way too left right it's
something like that
okay so large-scale low-resolution
abstractions tend to be the province of
the right high resolution detailed
knowledge structures tend to be the
province of the left the left is
linguistic that's where the detailed
structures manifest themselves in
articulation but the fundamental
difference between the left and right
isn't language versus non language the
fundamental distinction is relatively
explored and mastered versus relatively
unexplored and not mastered and that's
both in terms of structure the right
hemisphere has a less granular structure
it's less differentiated it's also
responsible mostly for negative emotion
especially in the prefrontal part and
the reason for that is well how do you
encounter what's absolutely unknown
imagination and emotion right I told you
that little experiment that you could do
if you're alone in a house and you hear
a strange noise at night in a room turn
off the lights and put your hand in the
room like your brain will just flash off
monsters like mad you know you'll be
nervous
because that what's in that room
something to make you nervous that's a
very low resolution category right it's
like it's a it's some indeterminate
manifestation of the category of things
that might hurt you very low resolution
but a very smart category it's like
don't put your hand in there you put
your hand in there and you watch your
imagination it's like monsters it'll
generate monsters like mat and that's
what the right hemisphere is doing it's
saying what's in there is an exemplar of
the category of things that are
dangerous here's a bunch of
images of those things and that thing in
there is going to partake of that
essence that's and that's a very low
resolution hypothesis that's kind of
what horror movies do with people you
know they sort of lead them through that
initial process and so and so that's
what the right the right hemisphere
seems to me to be dominated by dominated
by subcortical processes or the left
hemisphere is reversed the cortex is
more or less got Dominion and so the
right hemisphere well we'll walk through
this neurologically but the right
hemisphere is responds rapidly to what's
unknown and that's that subcortical the
hippocampus is doing an awful lot of
that noting a mismatch and then it's
using the right hemisphere to to
abstractly represent what the
possibility space is in relationship to
unexpected things and then the right
hemisphere is tracking that continually
what those unexpected things are and
coming up with models of what you
haven't yet mastered and that's kept
separate from the left hemisphere which
already has functional models and you
don't want to blast the left hemisphere
continually with anomalous information
because you blow out its structure and
then you don't know what to do so the
right hemisphere generates new models in
some sense out of nothing and then when
the time is right taps information into
the left hemisphere slowly so that it
doesn't disrupt its function too much
and that's a lot of that seems to happen
when you're dreaming by the way it
happens at night so and what happens
with the dreams you think about how
dreams work you might think of dreams as
part of that process where ideas come to
be so they're low resolution to begin
with mostly a majestic really highly
emotional and incoherent less coherent
why you can't be coherent unless you
know what to do ABCDEF if that's working
you've got coherent but if you're
dealing with something you don't know
you have to mock about with your
category structures and that's what
dreams do and you know when you're
interpreting a dream one of the things
you watch for is the dream the dream
presents this and then this that's
called metonymy by the way from a
literary perspective and what that
implies is this is related to this in
some way why else would they be Co
activated
you know people say well dreams are
random that's the stupidest theory I've
ever heard like white noise is random
dreams are not random
they're hard to understand but they're
anything but random they're more random
than real-life
well that's because what you don't
understand is really random and you're
organized and there has to be an
intermediary that sort of quasi random
between them or you never get from one
to the other and dreams and fantasies
this all of that is part of that process
that that stretches you out beyond what
you know into the absolute unknown and
so and your hemispheres are
differentially specialized for that so
roughly speaking right hemisphere
operation and unexplored territory
that's a really good way of thinking
about it you need a system that tells
you what to do when you don't know what
to do a huge part of the subcortical
structure is doing that to unknown
freeze then what
imagine right freeze emotions imagine
then explore then differentiate then
master that's the process that's the
process of learning and what you're
doing is you're you're transforming low
resolution representations of what's
frightening into high resolution
representations that enable you to
master it to take the world apart and to
make ingenious things out of it so
there's this very cool part of the
mesopotamian creation myth so that the
major hero whose name is Marduk
confronts the dragon of chaos
Tiamat whose feminine and he cuts her
into pieces and he makes the world out
of her pieces and one of his name's
there's he had 5060 names and I think
that was those were amalgams of tribal
gods and one of the names was he who
makes ingenious things out of the
conflict with time at absolutely perfect
because that's exactly what human beings
do right we confront that terrible
predatory potential that lies outside
our domain of experience and we make
ingenious things out of it and then we
talk about how we did it and then we
model how we did it and that's the basis
of our ethics and our morality and the
way that that ties in to think about one
of the things we talked about was that
the mythological hero was a
presentation not of the being that was
at the top of the dominant turkey but of
the being that was at the top of the set
of all possible dominance hierarchies
okay so here's a cool equation the hero
who goes out into the unknown to make
contact with the dragon and to bring
back the treasure is the same thing that
wins the battle across sets of dominance
hierarchies and that's how the two
things come together right it's so
brilliant it's so absolutely brilliant
and so it's the mythological hero the
mythological hero is the representation
of what's again not at the top of one
dominant turkey but at the top of all of
them that's the eye that's above the
pyramid why the eye because it pays
attention and that's what you do none of
this is this is not fiction
it's meta truth it's the right way to
think about it look let's say you're
socially anxious okay so what happens
when you're socially anxious you go to a
party your heart's beating why the party
is a monster why because it's judging
you and it's judging you it's putting
you low down the dominant hierarchy
because that's what a negative judgement
is and that interferes with your sexual
success and that means that you're being
harshly evaluated by nature itself right
so you are confronting that the dragon
of chaos when you go into the social
situation and so what do you do you like
this like you hunched over and that's a
little dominance I'm no threat it's like
well that's not going to get you very
far you know but that's a logical thing
to do in the in the face of a tyrant or
no threat you know you look at the king
and you're dead no threat I'm hunched
over and then what's happening
internally how are what are people
thinking about me what are people
thinking about me or am I looking stupid
am I looking foolish jeez I'm awkward I
hate being here man I'm sweating too
much it's all internalized right it's
all self focused the the eye isn't
worked the eye isn't working what do you
tell people stop don't stop thinking
about yourself because you can't it's
like don't think of a white elephant
white elephant whales and white elephant
you can't tell someone to stop thinking
about something because they get caught
in loop what you do with socially
people as you say look at other people
look at them right why because if you
look at them you can tell what they're
thinking and then you unless you're
unless you're terribly socialized and
some people are some people have no
social skills and so the reason they
can't go to a party is because they
don't even know how to introduce
themselves like they're just no one ever
taught them how to behave and so they're
really good candidates for behavior
therapy because you walk them through
the process of how you actually manifest
the procedures that are associated with
social acceptability but most people
aren't like that they have the ability
so if they're really introverted in high
in neuroticism they can usually talk
quite well to someone one-on-one why
because they look at them well if I look
at you it's another thing to do if
you're ever speaking to a group of
people never speak to the group of
people that doesn't exist you talk to
individuals and then they reflect for
you the entire group because they're all
entrained if you look at one person
they've broadcast to you what everyone's
thinking and you know how to talk to one
person so it's easy so as soon as you
focus on the person not you you post
your attention outward use your eye push
your attention outward and you start
watching well then all your automatic
mechanisms kick in and you stop being
awkward because if we're talking and I'm
looking here I don't know what you're
going to do next and I'm going to put
disjunctions into the like they're like
bad chords in the melody of our of our
conversation because the reason is I'm
not paying attention so that's why the
eye is the thing at the top of the
pyramid it's like the thing that enables
you to win the set of all possible
dominant turkeys is the eye
pay attention pay attention that's the
critical issue that's why the Egyptians
worshipped Horus
that's why Horus was the thing that
rescued Osiris from the from the depth
it's the capacity to pay attention what
do you pay attention to most what your
right hemisphere signals as anomalous it
attracts your attention like this isn't
going quite right I'm not looking at
that wrong that's what you look at
that's what you look at what
not going right because that's see
that's the terrible monster that might
eat you but it's also the place you get
all the information so that's why it's
useful to have discussions with your
enemies because they will tell you
things you do not know and that's such a
great thing because if you don't know
them well you're not very smart are you
you know there may be a time when you go
somewhere that's the thing you need to
know and maybe your enemy will tell you
why you're such a fool you know and a
bunch of other things that aren't true
too but even one thing that's accurate
it's like yeah thanks very much man
maybe I'll do some work on that I won't
have to carry that forward so and that's
part of the reason again why is a
terrible predator it's always the
terrible predator that has the gold it's
like the person who delivers the message
you do not want to hear so it's rough
it's rough but it doesn't matter who
life is rough okay so how are these
specialized the right hemisphere
operation and unexplored territory and
that unexplored territory emerges when
ever what you're doing doesn't work you
know you can conceptualize it as that
which is beyond the walls of the city
but the city is a category structure
abstractly abstractly but there's no
difference between the barbarians that
invade the walled city and the things
that happen in the world to damage your
category structure there they're the
same thing from up from a practical
perspective okay right hemisphere
operation and unexplored territory
negative emotion inhibition of behavior
that's this that's anxiety that's what
happens when the Medusa looks at you you
turn the stone right that's the basilisk
in Harry Potter it freezes you why
you're moving forward according to a
schema if you're moving forward properly
you're getting to where you want to go
and the schema is being validated
simultaneously I'm moving for it and the
map is correct something happens it's
unexpected what should you do stop what
else you going to do you stop first then
the predator can't see you right that's
the freezing reaction of a prey animal
so it's it's it
built very very deeply into very very
old circuits do that fact if it's a real
Orion Singh reflux to something that's a
normal she'll go like this and that's to
stop the thing that will jump on your
back from carrying out your throat and
that's really really fast
it's almost as fast as spinal sneak
reflex circuitry extraordinarily fast
and but you know that's conserved over
an evolutionary span that predator
defense system is at the bottom of your
cognitive apparatus everything be built
on that like it's a low-resolution
powder a higher-resolution pattern
that's the same pattern is built on top
of that then a higher-resolution pattern
of that and thought but that initial
architecture is duplicated across the
levels of differentiation of the nervous
system that's partly why these symbols
can be so archaic and still be accurate
it's still the way the world works
negative emotion inhibition of behavior
image processing right because image
thing about images is they're fast you
know a picture is worth a thousand words
okay you get the picture you know get
the picture is actually something you
say to someone if you say do you
understand right if you get the picture
is very very fast so the right
hemisphere manages that holistic
thinking that's that low resolution
thinking that generalizes across
instances pattern recognition pattern
generation and gross motor actions yeah
freeze and get the hell out of there
that's gross motor actions right
hemispheres very good at that that's why
if you're right-handed user if you're
right-handed you use your left
hemisphere to manage the really fine
motor details right you write with it
you write with it and because that's
very very if you're right-handed you
tend to use your left hand to open the
top of jars right you're use your left
hand that's a gross motor action I mean
sometimes people are more lateralized
than that but the left hemisphere is
specialized for the fine-grain things
that you know very well that's that's
exactly it okay the left hemisphere
while the left hemisphere which is
associated with positive emotion by the
way that's
utilize through operation and explored
territory so now what we might say is
that you spend your whole life try not
to have your right hemisphere turn on
because why would you want that that's
where the monsters pop up so you stay in
explored territory but maybe you also
tentatively expand its borders and the
left hemisphere seems to be involved in
that too so if you're curious about
something it's usually something usually
something minor enough so that it won't
blow your entire category structure if
you explore it now sometimes you get
unlucky and you're like Eve in the
Garden of Eden you go have a little chat
with this little snake that seems to be
no significance whatsoever and it feeds
you something Apple it feeds you
something and bang everything folds
apart right you collapse and you're out
there in history you're no longer in
your old paradise so activation of
behavior yeah well that's because
positive emotion is associated with
movement forward like if you're where
you want to be and things are going well
then your behavior should be activated
so that you go and get things now one of
the negative consequences of that is
that if you're really in a good mood
really happy you're going to be
impulsive and make mistakes you know
because you hear these don't headed
that's a very minor word people who are
always pushing happiness as the as the
key measure for for successful existence
it's so ill informed that it's
embarrassing that that even happens
positive emotion makes people impulsive
maniacs for example which is really if
you that's mania right bipolar disorder
if you're manic you're one happy person
way to happy everything is great nothing
but wonderful things that are beyond
your imagination are going to happen to
you and they're going to happen fast and
so you're down to the mall to buy
everything you can possibly get your
hands on because you have a hundred uses
for everything and then a week later you
know you crash into your depressive
episode and you realize that you're 150
thousand dollars in debt and you've
alienated everyone that you know it's
like that's untrammeled positive emotion
so how about know a peer index of pause
emotion is no way of determining whether
or not a system is working properly even
your own system you need a balance
between positive and negative emotions
plus positive emotions are absolutely
exhausting because if you're in a manic
episode it's like it's time to get
everything good right now fine but you
won't sleep for a week and then you die
because you just burned yourself to a
crisp and so to be overwhelmingly
enthusiastic about everything sounds
like a real blast and I've seen
full-blown manic so they're having
plenty of fun but it is not a pleasant
thing to behold they're just all over
the place and no yeah it's really not to
it it's really not good you need a
balance between these two systems
because the whole world isn't explored
territory bursting with nothing but
promise that's not the world the world
is that in the bounded space a little
bit with that absolute Horror Show going
out around the periphery and both of
your both systems need to be active in
order to keep you balanced people do
unfortunately sustained damage sometimes
to the left prefrontal cortex
responsible for positive emotion or the
right prefrontal cortex responsible for
negative emotion and if you sustained
right hemisphere prefrontal damage it
makes you inappropriately happy and
impulsive and you and your life just
goes you just spiral downhill because
you make nothing but impulsive decisions
and you know what the real world
consequence of that is you know get
drunk and be impulsive for one night you
can learn what the bloody consequences
of that are you try living like that for
a month independently of IQ that's the
other thing that's so interesting you
can blow out your left prefrontal cortex
and not suffer much of a decrease
especially in crystallized intelligence
but the fact that you're running on
nothing but sorry you late hemisphere
you're running on nothing but positive
emotion it's going to order you right
into the ground and then if you're
perhaps even more unlucky and you lose
the left prefrontal cortex then you're
permanently depressed because there's
nothing but the unexplored manifesting
itself we know that if you take
depressive depressed people and you
do EG analysis that they have
predominant lefting
predominant resting right hemisphere EEG
activation and so so that's roughly so
why is this well unknown territory known
territory you think well is that real
well it's real enough so that's how your
brain evolves that seems pretty damn
real so then we could think about it
subcortical e and we might as well do
that
this is mapped out on the hippocampus
more most particularly by jeffrey gray
who is influenced by so clove and
vinegared ova who are also students of
Luria jeffrey gray used cybernetic
theory that was developed by Norbert
Wiener and which is an AI which he is
the father of artificial intelligence
and some of that was actually integrated
as well in to Piaget Ian thought because
Piaget and white wine er Norbert liner
and Luria if I remember correctly all
went to the same conference back in the
early 1920s mid 1920s and heard Norbert
Wiener speak so that Co cybernetics
Theory got built into some of these
underlying theories and sort of
manifested itself everywhere so gray
gray uses a model very much like this
derived from cybernetic theory and so
here's the idea how does the brain work
you have a target in mind and you act to
to manifest the target you act to
transform the world into the target and
then you compare the consequence of your
actions to the target and if they
matched and that's a good thing and if
they don't match then that's what
knitwear negative emotion comes from
okay so how does that work the
hippocampus seems to be central to that
so it detects mismatch so so in the
classic behavioral theory so this would
be great theory you have your
expectations of the world that would be
your model and you have your sensory
input which is the real world and then
the hippocampus is mapping one on to the
other one from a top-down stream one
from the bottom up stream and saying
match match match match and as long as
everything matches then the hippocampus
this is an oversimplification keeps the
subcortical emotional systems inhibited
because you don't need them except for
maybe my
while positive emotion to keep you
moving forward if there's a mismatch
that's anxiety the anxiety system gets
disinhibited because it's so on it
doesn't get activated gets disinhibited
that freezes you and all the other
motivational systems are primed because
god only knows what you're going to have
to do next okay so then if you make a
mistake given that scheme you have to
modify the world in order to rectify the
mistake you have to modify your motor
output so that you put the world back in
order and that's basically Gray's model
but Gray's model is insufficient because
gray presumes that what you're comparing
your expectation with is the real world
but you don't have access to the real
world what really happens is that your
brain compares the model of the world
that you want to have happen so it's
desired and not expected with the model
of the world that you think is happening
they're both models there's no direct
contact with the truth and so what that
means and this is what's horrible about
this is that if your model fails it
doesn't only mean that you have to
adjust your expectation and change your
motor activity it means you might have
to bloody well retool your perceptions
well that's a lot more horrifying than
just having to change your motor output
if you betrayed me then I have to see
you differently and you know if we've
interacted a long time I've built up a
hell of a model of you you know it's
taken a tremendous amount of effort to
generate and I may have used that model
as a predicate for all sorts of other
plans which is what you do with an
intimate relationship and so then if you
do something that indicates a true
mismatch it isn't normally that I have
to adjust my actions god only knows what
I'm going to have to retool I may even
have to retool my perceptions of myself
I'm a lot more gullible than I thought I
was for example and god only knows what
the implications of that are if you're
close to me and you could do this to me
is that my flaw and environment am i
carrying that into other relationships
it's an absolute catastrophe and so gray
actually underestimated the degree of
severity of mismatch because he only
said well it was motor output
and and Andrey Andrey world adjusting
that would have to be repaired not
perception because like most behavior
see the behaviorist had this idea of
stimulus right the stimulus produces the
response it's like okay what stimulus
well they never went there they just
assumed that the stimulus spoke for
itself but it doesn't that's the
fundamental weakness of behavioral
theory is that the reason they could get
rid of the mind was because they hid it
invisibly inside the idea of the
stimulus which is all of a sudden not
just something that was a sense like a
piece of sense data but that had
motivations built into it well no you
know you can't do that the motivation
you can put the motivation in the object
but then it's no longer an object it's
something completely different
ok good let's stop there when you come
back I'm going to tell you a bunch of
stories ok so it will break for 15
minutes so imagine what happens when the
civilisation develops and it develops
out of an amalgam of tribal
organizations and so each of those
tribes has their own gods which is their
own sort of imaginative universe and
their attempt to make sense out of the
moral landscape of being and underneath
all of those representations is a
pattern and the reason there's a pattern
there is because all of those tribes are
made up of people and so there's going
to be it's like there's a domain within
which variation is going to occur so if
we're going to set up a structure that
works across time it's going to at least
be roughly predicated on the same
structures that a dominant hierarchy is
predicated on it's going to be
predicated on the same patterns of
interactions that would characterize the
chimpanzee troop you know there's this
basic biological what would you call it
there's a realm of biological necessity
that constitutes the boundary space
within which human interactions that
have to take place I mean I can't be so
violent that I kill everyone in my tribe
that's not to be very helpful because
I'm a tribal creature
so without the tribe what am I going to
do and so I have to be vaguely
acceptable to other people because
otherwise they'll kill me even if I'm
really really powerful they'll take
me down and so because I have to deal
with you and you and you and you and you
we're going to modify each other
continually and and within parameters
now the parameters are wide but they're
not non-existent and you know you can
see what those parameters are genuinely
if you look at a something like a wolf
pack or a chimpanzee tree because those
are stable across really the structure
itself is stable across at least
hundreds of thousands of years if not
millions of years and so there's a
there's a so Fran's de Waal shows for
example that with the chimpanzee troops
if you have a he studied them mostly at
the Artemis ooh and I would recommend
his writings highly de Waal de waa el
he's interested in the in prototypical
moral behavior among chimpanzees it's a
very interesting study and what he
showed for example is that if you have a
particularly the dominant dominance
hierarchy in chimpanzees is male there's
a female dominance hierarchy to that
overlaps the male and some of the
females are more dominant than many of
the males but the fundamental structure
looks like it's patriarchal roughly
speaking amongst pansies
if you put a really rough tough barbaric
brutal dictator chimpanzee at the top
his his reign tends to be unstable and
violent because he isn't good at
negotiating social support and so he
doesn't have any and so that means to
chimpanzees their friends can take them
out and so that's what happens and so
the despot chimp is an unstable leader
and Duvall has shown that the more
stable chimp leaders are more chimp anat
Arian I guess would be the right word
it's not humanitarian they they do they
have friends and you know friendship is
predicated on reciprocity even among
chimpanzees and so if a predicate of
power is reciprocity then that's one of
the things that alleviates the
dictatorial tendency so anyways so my
point is when a great civilization
emerges emerges from the amalgam of
tribal groups but and each of the tribal
groups has their
ethic but that isn't the ethics aren't
entirely separate from one another
that's why tribes can trade because they
do trade they interact with one another
it's kind of half remember here's how
heretofore separated tribes begin to
trade because you don't know you meet
each other across the river it's like
you got your bows and arrows and someone
makes a mistake and it's like warfare
and so but you don't want to start the
damn war because maybe you'll die so
you're sitting there with your bow and
arrows watching these guys and now you
know they're there and so then you go
back to your tribe and you think oh man
what the hell are we going to do about
this and one solution is well let's find
out where they are and then we'll go in
there at night well like well kill a
bunch of them or we'll wipe them out or
something like that
another solution might be did you see
all the neat stuff they had and so then
what do you do is you find a border area
and you go and you put some things out
there that are valuable and you run away
and then you watch from the trees and
you see what happens when these other
people discover these valuable things
that you left there and if they're like
little on the psychopathic side they
pick it all up and giggle and run away
and that's the end of that but if they
have any sense what they do is they
leave some cool stuff on the ground too
and then they run off and then you can
go pick up their cool stuff and leave
and then it's like step one in the trust
process and then maybe you do that you
know for a year and it starts to fall
into a cadence and then maybe you know
you get a little closer when you're
watching watching in the bush and then
maybe one day you have enough courage to
kind of come you send your biggest
ugliest guy out there and you know
they'd do the same and you know they
look at each other and finally they
shake hands or something like that and
trade and then well then you've got a
trading relationship established and so
you can see in that the emergence of a
what would you call it negotiated
consensual moral structure that allows
creating to take place and there's going
to be rules emerge right away which is
well you better leave me something
that's of approximately equal value or
are not going to play the game again
that's the thing that's so cool is that
if we only play a game once I can do
whatever I want and so that's that's
what cycles
they play with game 1 and then they go
play with someone else
but if we're going to play the same game
over and over and over it's like the
dominant hierarchy across time there's a
different rule for playing a game once
than there is for playing a game a
thousand times and if we're in a
relationship the game we want to play is
one that can be duplicated a thousand
times and there's really tight
constraints on that and so that's the
origin that you could consider that the
biological it's not even biological
exactly it's predicated in biology but
it's a consequence of continual
interaction the ethic emerges it's like
the rats that I told you about that you
know the rats that play with each other
the big rat has to let the little rat
win thirty percent of the time or the
little rat won't play anymore and so
because the little that that's the
biological the biological framing the
limitation is the little rat doesn't
want to lose all the time that just
produces negative emotion it's not fun
it's not motivating so why would the
little rats go play again so the the
constraint on our interactions are our
biological constraints and they manifest
themselves in the patterns way across
time and there isn't any difference
between you and me interacting across
time then there is between you and me
acting play in the next hour so with
everyone in this room it's the same
thing it's just continual human
interactions and I think emerges from
that now different groups are going to
code that ethic differently so they're
going to come up with different
imagistic representations and different
stories now one of the things they're
trying to figure out is well let's do it
let's do it in the tribal way you have
to do this inside the tribe too you have
a hundred people and 10 of them are
leaders in one way or another and then
out of that 10 you think well who's the
who's the best person so you have to
have a hierarchy of value to determine
what the most important aspect of the
ethic is it's going to be something like
trust because that's the predicate for
continued interaction trustworthiness
it's not any really really any different
than honesty it's not really any
different from telling the truth so
there's a really powerful necessity for
honesty to
merge as a as a canonical value caring
might emerge power might emerge right
the ability to exert physical power
especially in places where war is a
continual is continually likely and in
lots of tribal landscapes it's just
non-stop tribal trade and warfare so but
but you can see how different ethics
would emerge as canonical depending to
some degree on the situation but Trust
is a really crucial one because without
that there's no relationships ok so
you've got tribe and it's got its tribal
gods and it's and its traditions and all
of that it's representation of the being
in its images and stories and then
you've got tribe II and you've got tried
see and you've got tribe D and now
they're all coming together so what
happens exactly well the tribes can go
to war or they can talk and what we're
thinking about a communication that
might be extending across a thousand
years you have your beliefs I have my
beliefs I can overwhelm you I can
subsume you but even then I'm likely
just to get indigestion from doing it
it's very very difficult to wipe out a
set of beliefs without wiping out all of
the people and that kind of nullifies
the utility of unification the more
there are of you the better you can
defend yourself against other
organizations that are trying to be
larger so there's a powerful self
preservation impetus to cooperation and
so one of the things you see happening
in the development of the stories in the
Old Testament for example we know this
about Genesis in particular that there
were at least this is this is relatively
recently so say for 3,000 years ago not
50,000 years ago there were two
different stories there's two different
stories in the Genesis account told by
two different storytellers and people
who are very good at textual analysis of
being able to separate them and they
were put together I don't remember when
again it's probably about something
between 2,000 and 3,000 years ago they
were put together by what appeared to be
a single editor and so he took these
disparate accounts and
try to organize them into something that
looked like a logical narrative and that
was part of the process by which
different tribal representations of the
world were brought into something under
which the tribes as you as a unit could
simultaneously exist so you can think
about it as a competition between
imagistic representations across time
and then the emergence of some unifying
narratives that that captures the key
elements of all of them well enough to
bring them into some sort of Union and
it has to be a story with motivational
power because otherwise no one will
caught on to it and it has to be a story
that keeps uncertainty at bay because
otherwise it doesn't have any utility it
has to be a functional story so I'm
going to tell you a story like that in
the story of Marduk and it's the
Mesopotamian story and Mesopotamia is
one of the earliest civilizations and it
emerged as a consequence of the amalgam
of of Middle Eastern tribes so that over
a very long period of time you could
think that the gods of all of these
tribes were worrying in an abstract
space in a conceptual space and that
would be the space of argumentation and
conflict and out of that a meta story
emerged and this is the meta story and
it's one of a host of similar meta
stories that came out of the Middle East
one of which is the account in Genesis
okay so here's the story so there are
two primary deities to begin with AB su
and time at now in order to understand
that well here's how the Mesopotamians
conceptualized the world
there was a let's call it a disc that's
saltwater why well what happens when you
go to the end of the continent and saw
water everywhere right so wherever you
go you run into saltwater so that's the
disc that surrounds everything now why
is it a disc the world is a dome on a
disc why well say you're standing in the
middle of the field what does the world
look like dome on a disc so it's a
phenomenological representation so the
bottom of the dome is the ground
which you stand what happens if you dig
you hit water fresh water so the Dome of
the land is on a disk of fresh water
what happens if you go to the edge of
the land you run into salt water the
Dome of the land is on a disk of fresh
water on a disk of salt water okay those
are the two God's time at is God of salt
water and absolute fresh water and it's
it's happenstance in some sense because
that's the masculine and the feminine
and they could be attributed all sorts
of different geographical areas so for
example see if I can think of a good
example doesn't matter I'll just leave
that for now okay so the two primary
gods are absolute and time out time out
is female and absolute is male and
they're locked together in an
inseparable embrace okay so how do you
understand that easy
yin and yang it's the same idea here's
here's another representation this is a
cool one I've got a couple of them here
that are really cool this is from China
so this is so this is Fuxi and you I
think I've got that right but I just
love that reverence it's so insanely
cool this representation so you see the
sort of the primary mother and father of
humanity emerging from this underlying
snake-like entity with its tails tangled
together
I think that's a ripoli do believe this
although it's very complicated to
explain why I really believe that's a
representation of DNA so and that that
representation that entwined double
helix that is everywhere you can see it
in Australian Aboriginal art and I'm
using the Australians as an example
because they were isolated in Australia
for like 50,000 years there's the most
archaic people that were ever discovered
and they have clear representations of
these double helix structures in their
art so and those are the two giant
serpents out of which the world is made
roughly speaking it's the same thing you
see that in the staff of Asclepius which
is the heel
symbol that the physicians use although
usually that's only one snake but
sometimes it's too so so so that's a
that's a Chinese representation and then
there's a there's this that's the
Egyptian representation we talked about
the Egyptian story the other day right
we talked about Isis and Osiris so there
they are cobras their tails are twined
together see they emerge out of that
that's the dragon of chaos that
manifests itself as culture in nature
that's the representation that's
unbelievably cool so okay so anyways
back to back to to the Mesopotamian
story so absolute and time Adar their
primordial deities nature and culture
they're entwined together and they give
rise to the to their first category of
children and those are the I think you
could think about them as the Elder Gods
now I what do they represent well the
question is what did the gods represent
and they represent they represent sort
of like primary modes of being it's
something like that so think about Ares
or Mars the God of War well that's
that's a representation of single-minded
aggression and then you can think about
eros or Venus which is a primary
representation of sexuality and you
might say well why are those deities
well that's simple they live forever and
they control you and their personalities
so that's that for that it's like yes
obviously you know and you know that
you're under the sway of anger you're
not in control of yourself if you're
under the sway of erotic possession you
make a fool out of yourself you're a
tool of the power that drives the
continuation of the species forward
hunger is the same thing any primordial
motivational Drive we've conceptualized
in this class of the personality but
those are transcendent personalities and
their eternal their forever and so
that's why the Greeks for example
thought that human beings were just the
playthings of the gods
this idea is echoed in the Mesopotamian
story so then you can think about it
sort of neural developmentally as well
is that out of out of nothing
of culture nature emerges say the
two-year-old the two-year-old is a
battleground of primary motivational
forces and something like that is being
hinted at in the Mesopotamian creation
story the first the first progeny of the
fundamental union of chaos and order
absolute and time at is the
proliferation of these primary
motivational forces they're sort of like
the Titans or the or the what it wasn't
the Greek gods kept in the underneath
the mountain that's loose what's the
name of that they're like Prime their
earthquakes and fires and that sort of
thing their primordial force it's okay
anyways so these children are produced
and what happens they're very noisy they
run around doing all sorts of things you
can think about them as grown-up
two-year-olds causing all sorts of
trouble the first thing they do is kill
apps ooh and and make their homeowners
corpse
that's brilliant now the story doesn't
say much about absolute other than that
the the culture deity the primary
culture identity is not elaborated up
that much in the Mesopotamian story and
I think that's probably because at the
time of the Mesopotamian civilization
was knew enough so that we really hadn't
mapped the mythology of culture the
Egyptians did that much more and I know
I told you that story first but that's
just how it goes so the the Elder Gods
make their their home on the corpse of
absolute well what does that mean well
that's that's sort of how it is you
inhabit the corpse of culture right it's
the dead past and but but it's not just
the dead path one of the things that's
very cool about the Mesopotamian story
is that the Elder Gods are foolish
enough to kill it it's the death of God
by the way it's no different from what
Nietzsche pronounced
this has been going on for a very very
long time it's collapse of belief
systems they kill it carelessly because
they don't understand what it is that
they need to survive they kill it
carefully carelessly and then they try
to live on the corpse I think that's
what the postmodern is do by the way
because they assume we have this
tremendous system of value that's being
built up across time and it sustains us
and everyone is criticizing it and
criticizing it and trying to destroy it
as well we live in its corpse and that
will nourish us forever it has to be
replenished and there's nothing in the
post modernist philosophy that can act
to replenish anyways to kill up to what
happens when you kill order chaos comes
back tie them out now this is time out
here feminine but also the dragon so
it's it's you think out of this
fundamental reptilian treasure Bearer
culture and nature emerge and they can
pull back into that very rapidly so
here's an example you've all seen
Sleeping Beauty I presumed how many of
you have seen Sleeping Beauty the Disney
film how many of you have it okay so
there's a couple that haven't there's a
scene in Sleeping Beauty where the Evil
Queen has has imprisoned the prince
who's going to wake Sleeping Beauty up
so he's the logo so that he's that he's
the heroic individual or he's that
element of her consciousness that wakes
her up you can read it either way she's
got him trapped in a dungeon
so she's the kind of ultimate ultimate
eatable mother you know she's the mother
that has her 40 year-old son in the
basement who is like overweight and
unhealthy and watched and watching video
games and being covered with cheeto dust
and she always like seeds and sandwiches
so he won't leave you know and she says
oh it's good thing you didn't go out the
world make some poor woman miserable so
anyway so that's the Evil Queen he's got
the hero trapped in the dungeon so he
goes out he escapes and then she goes
after him to try to bring him back and
turns into the dragon that's what
happens in Sleeping Beauty so that's
that reversion of the of the archetype
into it's even more primordial force so
anyway so time at is kind of an amalgam
of feminine nature and also this more
underlying primordial symbol so anyway
she is not happy she is not happy that
these her children killed her husband
and so she thinks oh well not for these
creatures women
going to do them in the flood myth the
same idea so what happens in the story
of Noah this happens worldwide is that
human beings get all corrupt and make a
lot of racket and break all sorts of
rules and God thinks oh well you know
not for you we'll just bring in a flood
and wipe Yolo that's chaos returning you
destabilize order too badly there's a
flood and that brings with it all sorts
of new things because it's water but it
just drowns you it drowns you now Noah
is a good man so he can ride out the
flood he's the hero that can go down
into the chaos and then back up because
he hasn't let go of his morality despite
the fact that the entire society has
disintegrated so he saves everything so
it's it's like Moses crossing the Red
Sea and then coming out the other side
same same sort of idea anyways so tie
him out she's uh she's not happy and
these dogs are careless to it impulsive
they're making a lot of noise and their
activity disturbs her you know and you
can see echoes of that fear that
mythological fear in modern
consciousness because we tell ourselves
the same story right the story is if we
keep running around making enough racket
mother nature is going to take offense
and wipe us out and that's the story
that's at the bottom of the sort of
apocalyptic element of the global
warming apocalypse it's like if we if we
mock about badly enough nature will take
its revenge okay fine it's true it's
true it's so it's a story that's always
been true so anyways the gods are making
a lot of noise they're being impulsive
and then they make the fatal error of
killing AB su and that's a big mistake
and so time at thanks alright now for
this she wakes up and she thinks I'm
going to wait them all out now that
these gods their God they I mean they're
not trivial characters but they're
pretty worried because their gods but
Tiamat is their mother she gave birth to
she's Mother Nature and if she's angry
about it then the jig's up so what time
out does is he prepares this army of
monsters and that they're described
there's I think 13 different kinds of
monsters and they're chimeric images
they're images of you know
they're like dragons they're half snake
and half bird and half animal and
they're monstrous images and they're
sort of the Mesopotamians attempt to
imagistic aliy represent those things
that might come forward as an onslaught
and so generates a whole 13 major
monsters and then puts a whole army
behind them and she elects one of them
king who is his name as head monster
so he's for all intents and purposes
he's an early representation of Satan
he's like king of the bad guys and it's
important to know about him because if
something happens later in the story so
so time adds preparing her army of
monsters to chimeras to wipe out the
gods and so they're like shorting out
about this but while they're doing it
they're still making a lot of racket and
living the highlife in absolutes corpse
and and propagating and while they're
doing that they send out one god after
another to combat time out and they all
come back failed so whatever these Elder
Gods are whatever they represent they're
not whatever it is that can confront
chaos successfully and prevail their
powers but they're not whatever that is
that ultimate power and that's what the
Mesopotamians are trying to figure out
who or what is king of the gods and king
of the gods is the thing that confront
chaos and regenerate order so so they
keep producing new gods and one day they
produce Marduk
he's bored and Marduk has a whole new
category of God and every one of the
guards knows it and he's got some very
strange attributes one of them is he
could speak magic words
and so when mardik speaks the night sky
transforms into the day sky advise versa
so he's he's the verbal capacity it's a
massive discovery it's a massive
discovery by the Mesopotamians because
it's the first time we know of that the
idea that it's the capacity for
communicative speech as the primary
daddy should be at the top of the
dominant turkey it's one of the most
remarkable discoveries of the ages and
he also has eyes all the way around his
head so Marduk is the thing that can
speak and see and it's the thing that's
so
all the gods think wow well this is a
whole new thing man how about you go out
and combat time at well it doesn't sound
like much of a picnic you know the
logical thing for any sensible god to
say is how about no but Marduk doesn't
say that he says look I'll make you guys
a deal you get yourself together in a
whole you know and you have a vote for
all intents and purposes and you vote me
king of the gods and allow me from here
on in to determine destinies that's
exactly what the Mesopotamian say he
gets the tablet of destiny and he's now
in control of it so the Mesopotamians
are working out this idea that it's the
thing that can see and that can talk
that should be the thing that guides
destiny especially if destiny involves
having to go into combat with chaos
itself and restructure the world and so
Marduk says those are the terms I'll do
it but I'm king of the gods and they all
think well at the fools can quote didn't
get killed anyway so you know what do we
have to lose and so they agreed and so
Martin goes out to combat timeout and he
takes a net and a sword and he if I
remember correctly he fills her with a
wind which is I believe part of the
manifestation of this voice this voice
idea he fills her with a wind he
encapsulate her in a net now think about
what that means
you know psychologists even used this
word phrase Noma logical net and Anoma
logical net is this is the network of
concepts that you use to encapsulate
something new in an idiot all structure
and so the idea of putting something in
a net is to put boundaries around it
right and to constrain it and so some of
that's actually well you can capture a
predator in a net and then cut it up but
there's no difference between that
there's a there's a tight analogy
between that and cat encapsulating
something novel in a conceptual Network
which then enables you to cut it up into
something useful okay so that's what
happened Martin goes out he confronts
time at he overcomes the monsters and he
kills kinou and so and then he makes he
cuts time head into pieces and he makes
the world and that's the world that
human beings live
on and he makes the human beings to
serve the gods okay so that's the first
part of the story now he also kills King
knew and he makes human beings out of
the blood of King you now that's a hell
of a story right because King U is king
of the demons and human beings are the
creature that's made out of the blood of
the king of the demons it's a very
similar idea to the idea the later sort
of Egyptian and judeo-christian ideas
that there's a satanic element to being
that's also characteristic of human
beings and part of that is well what's
the difference between human beings and
every other element of being and the
answer that is human beings can deceive
you right we're the only creatures that
can do that we're capable of deception
voluntary deception were capable of
malevolence and so that's echoed as well
in the story in Genesis because when
Adam and Eve eat the apple they wake up
the scales fall from their eyes they
recognize that they're naked and they
know the difference between good and
evil which means they can do evil and it
took me a long time to figure that out
what that meant so Majid because there's
a causal sequence a the snake offers you
something that you and Jeff it wakes you
up the scales fall from your eyes so now
you can see the first thing you do is
you realize that you're naked what does
that mean well human being stand upright
the most vulnerable part of us is front
and center to be hurt but also to be
judged right to be naked is to be that's
terrifying you want to not die you want
to cover yourself up and so that's the
recognition of nakedness but then you
might say well why does the knowledge of
good and evil emerge from that as soon
as you know you're naked and vulnerable
you know how to hurt other people you're
not a predator anymore because they'll
just tear you apart and eat you like
they don't want you to suffer although
they don't care they don't want you to
suffer they just want to eat you but
once I know what hurts me I know what
hurts you and then I can turn that into
an art and people have done that and so
that's that's why the knowledge of evil
comes immediately as a consequence of
the knowledge of of nakedness and that's
associated with the same idea that human
beings are made out of the blood of King
Oh nasty stories but very you know
they're messing with the fundamental
structure reality they want to get this
right
one of the cool things about this story
so okay so that's Martin now here's
what's so interesting about that the
Mesopotamians they've got this story
about the deities and how they organize
themselves to respond to the emergence
of chaos and how to master it you you go
after it you you declare yourself to
sing at the top of the dormant of Turkey
your eyes and speech you go out there
voluntarily you encapsulate the chaos
you cut it into pieces and you make the
world that makes you top god brilliant
bloody absolutely phenomenally brilliant
so what happens that's what's happening
in the heavenly domain let's say what
happens in the earthly domain the
Emperor of the Mesopotamians is Marduk
he's a manifestation of Marduk on earth
and he has to be a good Marduk that's
because you might say well why should
you be king well the answer to that is
while you're most powerful no that's not
going to work some other weasels will
take you out why should you be king well
because you pay attention and you speak
properly and you keep chaos at bay and
you make ingenious things happen as a
consequence so that's what the bloody
Mesopotamians were trying to work out
what should be sovereign and why okay so
what did they do in the New Year
ceremony so imagine that they're there
they're the king is in a walled city
right so that's the Kings at the top of
the dominant Turkey he's the eye at the
top of the pyramid in a walled city with
chaos outside chaos is outside that's
the domain of time at at the New Year
ceremony the old year we know about that
we still have this idea the old year is
an old man the new year is about to be
born there's an intermediary period of
chaos that's New Year's Eve right that's
the intermediate period of chaos where
all the rules are temporarily suspended
which is why you can go out and party
like there's no tomorrow New Year's Eve
and before the new year is born the
Mesopotamian Emperor and all of his
retinue and the people go outside the
city on New Year's Eve and they take
statues that represent the gods and they
act out the story that I just told you
with the statues and as part of that the
emperor has to take off all his garb his
garments that make him King and me
in front of the priest and the priest if
I remember correctly slaps him with a
glove it's something like that and tells
him that he has to tell everyone why in
the last year he wasn't a very good
marduk and how he's going to do better
in the future which is exactly by the
way what do you do when you make your
New Year's what do you call those yes
the ones you immediately break the next
day but it's the same it's this renewal
idea that happens that it happens in the
depth of darkness in the middle of the
winter before the light comes back right
that's why it's set up that way so so
anyways and so that so as long as the
emperor is a good mardik then that's why
he gets to the Emperor and if he's not a
good mark then well someone else should
the Emperor so so that's how that works
and there's some representations of it
so there's there's time out there sort
of spirit matter combination winged
dragon right the thing that we've seen
so many times and there is Marduk he's
got angel wings why the wings I don't
know exactly why the wings I mean he's
obviously being assimilated to the idea
of a bird I don't know if the idea of
the far-seeing capacity of the bird was
there for the Mesopotamians highly
probable but also the bird is something
that flies up above everything else and
the conceit for long distances so it's
an aerial spirit it's close to God and
all of that so so there's a very
primordial representation of the same
thing look how much imagination does it
take to see that that's the story of
human beings encountering the unknown
you know when you know the code it just
seems self-evident yes well there is
he's got his bow and arrow you know and
he's out there fighting the monsters of
the unknown and that's part that how
human beings have survived yeah yeah
that's and then here he's writing this
great big snake so that's another
representation of the same kind of thing
okay so let me just think for a minute
you'll figure out what I want to do next
if I want to go somewhere next I guess
what I'll do right now is I'll just show
you some additional pictures so we've
laid out the conceptual world to some
degree right
mentioned that you can think about it as
the potential itself that's the dragon
of chaos and then nature which has a
positive and a negative element creation
and destruction and culture which has a
positive and negative emotion element
there reverse day because it's the
positive element of culture that
protects you against the negative
element of nature and the negative
element of culture can be destroyed by
the new coming in from the from the
natural world and then the archetypal
individual positive and negative as well
that's the that's the entire story
roughly speaking and I showed you its
manifestations and figures like this so
you have this is called the open virgin
the opening virgin because that those
two halves can be closed so there's
Mother Nature roughly speaking or the
mother of God depending on how you look
at it and inside her nature culture the
patriarchy the culture supports the
suffering individual who voluntarily
accepts death and mortality as the price
to be paid for being that's what that
image represents it's absolutely
unbelievable and then you see all these
people that decide here are gazing
uncontrollably at this image which is of
course exactly what's happened over the
last two thousand years at least in part
of the world because there's there's a
tremendous idea encapsulated inside that
image and the image the idea is
something like the voluntary acceptance
of suffering is key to its transcendence
and that's that's a that's a crucial
psychotherapeutic truth right things
that bother you need to be confronted
voluntarily you have to accept them you
have to accept them you think well how
far does that go well we don't know it
works in small things it works with
phobias it works with traumas traumas
are usually associated with death or
disease or malevolence
so that's pushing it pretty far there
doesn't seem to be a limit to the to the
idea that the voluntary confrontation
with the things that are terrifying is
curative there doesn't seem to be a
limit to that there's an example in the
story of Exodus when Moses is leading
the Israelites through the desert they
fragment because while they're out of
tyranny so they don't know what to do
it's all chaotic and you know this Moses
character yeah you got the amount of
each
now they're in the desert and there's
nothing to eat and like why should they
listen to him and so they start
worshipping all sorts of idols and
that's kind of like the fragmentation of
what holds them centrally together and
so what does God do he's not very happy
about that
whoo so he sends a bunch of poisonous
snakes into the desert to bite them all
he thinks not for these people not chaos
returning right in the form of these
poisonous snakes and so the Israelites
are kind of sick and tired of being
bitten by poisonous snakes so they go
back to Moses and they say well you know
I know we've wandered off the path here
and we didn't think you were the
greatest guy there for a while but you
know maybe who could have a little chat
with God and see what he could do about
these poisonous snakes and so so Moses
entreats God to do something about the
snakes and what God tells people to do
the strangest thing he says make a snake
in the image make a bronze snake and put
it on a post and have everyone look at
it and everyone who goes to look at the
snake won't be bitten by the poisonous
snakes anymore I just saw this it's it
just crazy that idea it's crazy so and
I'll tell you something else else that's
very interesting so in that in the
Christian story Christ assimilates
himself to that snake that was put on
the post in the desert says exactly the
same thing that that that has to be
looked at because that's the pathway to
salvation roughly speaking it's exactly
the same idea it's the worst thing that
can possibly happen so you look upon it
and meditate upon it and that's the key
to transcending it well so that's the
idea that's encapsulated in that image
so it's you know it's no wonder that
these ideas had to be expressed in
images because they're so unbelievably
complicated that they're almost
incomprehensible so they come out first
in the image they come out first in the
story because they're just and plus
they're so difficult to believe what the
last thing you would think if you were
being bitten by poisonous snakes was
that you should make a bronze image of
one and put it on a stick so that you
could go look at it I mean there's a
magical element to that but it's psycho
therapeutically exactly right so I had
this client and she had a dream about
what what she was she was having a
really rough car and she she was a
pretty good dreamer
had this dream that she was walking down
a road by there was a ocean on one side
and there was a sort of sand dunes on
the other side and she looked up and
there's this guy with a huge Python that
had that had been out there showing it
to everyone and she took a look and he
invited her to come take a look at the
snake but she refused and walked on and
so she told me that dream she was also
quite imaginative so I said look let's
let's try something first of all tell me
about the snake handler and she said
well he's kind of a charlatan he's a
show-off he's a he's a fake and I'm
afraid that if I went up to the crowd
and where the snake was that they would
force me to touch it and so I thought
okay so that's why you walked by I said
okay so let's play a game so you sit
there and bring that dream image to mind
close your eyes bring the dream image to
mind but let's play with a little bit
like young technique of active
imagination let's play with it a little
bit so go up there you know imagine that
you go up there and you kind of have to
do this like you're daydreaming you know
you can't force it you have to play with
it like you would when you're
daydreaming which is you're kind of half
doing it voluntarily and it's half
manifesting itself it's kind of a
gateway between you and the collective
unconscious that's another way of
thinking about it and anyways I said
okay so go up there and the first thing
we're going to do is figure out what are
you going to do if the crowd tells you
that you have to touch the snake or get
close to it because she needed a defense
because it isn't up to other people to
force her to do that so we we practiced
what she might say like no I'm I'm
comfortable here I'm just going to stand
in the background just going to look at
it and get accustomed to it I don't need
you to push me forward so she felt
pretty good about that so I kind of
armed her with a defense so then she
could pretend to go up and take a look
at the snake and I said well the first
thing you should do is take a look at
the snake handler and see if he's who
you think he is and so she did that in
her imagination she said no he doesn't
seem to be the charlatan at all he's got
this snake that is his you know
something he takes care of and he just
has come out here to show the people and
let people look at the snake and so she
said yes I said was he someone that you
could trust or someone you shouldn't
trust you have to ask both those
questions because otherwise you're
leading
witness right you don't want to tell
people what to think you have to let
them figure it out for themselves so and
she said no I think he's somebody that
should be trusted and I said okay well
so what do you think that you could go
up there and and and you know maybe lay
your hands on the snake and touch the
snake and she said she wasn't sure about
it but we went through it and she was
able to do it and so it's the same so
she had to she had to make contact she
had to voluntarily make contact with
with the this terrible snake that's at
the bottom of being that's at the bottom
of the tree of existence right that's
where the snake is it's wrapped around
the tree well why well partly because we
lived in trees and that's where the damn
snakes were down there on the ground
where we didn't know right and that's
the divine tree of being that and so
well you have to get the hell out of the
tree and go confront the snakes and then
that's the that's the way out at least
in principle so that's kind of what that
means um show you here's another image
of the same thing what I like about this
you see the fact that the culture the
patriarchy God the Father will say here
is holding the suffering individual in
his arms and that's encapsulated by
nature it's it's very much like the
story in Pinocchio where Geppetto
Pinocchio wasn't able to go down into
the depths and confront the terrible
monster at the bottom of being without
having support from his father even
though his father ended up trapped
inside the whale if he wouldn't have
been supported to begin with he wouldn't
have been able to do it and you know
I've really seen this and I really seen
this in people it's a hell of a thing
not to have the confidence of your
father it's really really hard on people
you know if your father is someone who
says to you you can do it I really
believe that you can do it I'll support
you in what you're doing I think that
you can sort it out and then acts
towards you in that way that's a gift
that really almost no one else can
provide you with mothers obviously
provide I think they provide the same
kind of gift but earlier you know
because the mother has to take care of
the infant when the infant has just
completely dependent and so a neces
Erickson's idea to Eric Erickson is the
mother is is the person
establishes the relationship that allows
the developing person to manifest trust
real trust while you're being carried
for crying out loud you know you can be
dropped and the mother is also the
source of food but the father seems to
be something like thee and I'm being I'm
obviously parsing these things farther
apart than they can be need to be
because the father can play a nurturing
role and the mother can play an
encouraging role but we'll keep it
simple for now the father seems to be
the thing that supports and encourages
it says well yeah you know your little
as small and all of that and you're
subject to destruction and and and
bullying and social pressure and all
that but I know you can do it I know you
can do it and there's a force in that
that's unbelievable and people who don't
have that have a have a hell of a time
it's actually one of the things that's
quite fun about doing psychotherapy
because you get people who have damaged
father figures it's harder with the
damaged mother figure a because it's so
bloody deep you know I had a client who
I just I just thought she was a
remarkable person but her relationship
with her mother was really disrupted it
was really really hard to she says she
would she told me it was like something
had been torn out of her at an early age
that couldn't be replaced it's real
because he just can't be someone's
mother you know it's really hard you're
just not there enough for that but you
can sort of be someone's surrogate
father that's a that's a role you can
play later and that's what educators do
at least to some degree although now
they're trying to be mothers and
providing safe spaces and all of that
which is not really all that appropriate
so that so the father is an encouraging
figure and allows the individual at
least in principle to support the
catastrophe of being voluntarily and so
anyway so those you know those images
are just be a brilliant beyond belief
absolutely brilliant beyond belief ok
well that's probably a good place to
stop and so so we've got through the the
two front these two fundamental stories
remember in the Egyptian story you have
much more development of the figure of
Osiris whose equivalent to absolute and
the Egyptians sort of walked through how
this state becomes corrupt and
deteriorates and what the individual has
to do in relationship to the state as
well as in relationship to the chaos
itself so in the Mesopotamians
story it's mostly abscess dead and
mardik makes a new society out of the
pieces but it's pretty damn implicit you
know it's not detailed whereas by the
time the Egyptians come along they say
well Oh Cirrus was great he's corrupted
by Seth he has an evil brother so that's
the tyrannical element of the state he's
overcome by the evil brother which is
the tendency of every bureaucratic
system everywhere things fall apart
chaos comes back up the hero is born
takes on the corruption of the state and
goes into the underworld which is like
confronting time at but there I like to
have the stories in parallel because one
of it is the confrontation with absolute
unknown time at and the other is the
revivification of the state even though
the stories also overlap and so in the
Egyptian story the soul just like Marduk
was the the model for the Emperor the
combination of Osiris and Horus was the
model for the Pharaoh and then there was
an idea that emerged out of Egypt this
was called the democratization of Osiris
and it's I think part of what gave rise
to the entire judeo-christian idea set
of ideas because the Jews hypothetically
came out of Egypt right so their
thinking is very deeply influenced by
Egyptian ideas the pharaoh was the
amalgam of Osiris and Horus and the
amalgam of Osiris and Horus was his
immortal soul the Pharaohs immortal soul
and the Pharaoh was allowed to use the
symbolism of the conjunction of Osiris
and Horus but as the Egyptian society
has developed the aristocracy started to
get to use that symbol so it started
moving down the hierarchy the idea that
it wasn't only that the Pharaoh was
Osiris and Horus it was been it with the
aristocracy and then by the time the
Greeks came along it was all men who
were part of the political structure and
then by the time the Christians came
along it was no no wait a minute this
applies to everyone men women and not
only male and female alike but also not
just star wart upholders of the state
but criminals tax collectors prostitutes
outcasts everyone had this Osiris Horus
soul inside of them and
were entitled to be treated as if they
were intrinsically valuable as a
consequence of that and that's the
bedrock as far as I'm concerned that's
the bedrock idea upon which Western
civilization is predicated it's the
sovereignty of the individual and the
individual sovereign why the individual
is the I that's up above the pyramid the
individual is the thing that can
dominate sets of dominant turkeys the
individual is the thing that play is not
the game but the metagame the individual
is the thing that Reviva Phi's the dead
culture the individuals the thing that
that goes out to combat chaos and
generate something valuable as a
consequence and that's why it's
sovereign and valuable that's the
foundation of our legal system and our
culture so so think about it as the
emergence as an emergent property of
Enlightenment ideals is dangerous
because that's four hundred years who
cares about four hundred years this is
forever and forever is a lot more firm
grounding than four hundred years it's
not a set of rational ideas it's way way
deeper than that so okay good enough
we'll see you in a week